c'est une de mes priorités j mais la
tension l'ardeur c'était en janvier
dernier depuis le ministre françois
philippe champagne serait sur le point
de conclure une entente avec le cn
selon nos sources le pont de québec
reviendrait dans le giron d'ottawa qui
pourrait ainsi en assurer l'entretien et
l'avenir
l'entente comprendrait une compensation
monétaire du canadien national
le montant associé au transfert de
propriété ne nous a pas été dévoilés
pour l'instant mais il s'agirait d'une
somme substantielle qui couvrirait une
partie importante des coûts de remise en
état
les dernières estimations pour la
peinture et la restauration du pont
était de près de 600 millions de dollars
le porte parole du cabinet du ministre
de l'infrastructure reste toutefois
discret sur les progrès dans le dossier
il ne souhaite pas spéculer sur la
conclusion des négociations à ce moment
ci mais confirme que les canaux de
communication sont ouverts et qu'il ya
des échanges fréquents entre le ministre
et le cn
selon nos sources pour superviser
l'entretien et la restauration du paon
le fédéral mettrait aussi en place une
société d'état comme celle qui est
responsable des ponts jacques cartier et
champlain depuis 1978 du côté du cn le
porte parole confirme que le cn et le
gouvernement du canada sont en
discussions constantes sur plusieurs
dossiers d'infrastructures incluant le
pont de québec
cependant dit-il nous nions
catégoriquement qu'il y à une entente
sur la peinture du pont de québec sur le
point d'être signé dans la capitale le
dossier de la restauration du pont est
prioritaire pour la communauté et les
maires les comité de sauvegarde du pont
ont été créés au fil des ans en 2016 la
chambre de commerce et d'industrie de
québec a tenu un colloque sur son avenir
en plus de confier un mandat à une
société de comptable pour que soit
examiné le dossier l'hypothèse de la
mise en place d'une société de gestion
avait alors été évoquée dans la région
les élus libéraux eux ne manquent pas
une occasion de rappeler qu'ils appuient
le projet de restauration
ah qu'il est que les projets
prioritaires on peut financer à court
terme 6 1
le projet de transport moderne
gainey et 2 notre premier premier lié et
un le pont qu'il est ici dylan bus et à
radio canada québec